Hey youtubers it’s Charlie I’ve almost
settled on a name, so pretty soon my hello
and the high five stuff will change.
This week is like the big week to start getting
ready for everything.
This video is going to be my Agents Of SHIELD
season 2 preview.
They’ve cast a bunch of big characters from
the comics and they will be doing a big crossover
with Avengers 2 when it comes out next spring.
So I’m going to start with what the new
arc of the season is, then do new characters
and then explain what’s going on with the
movie crossover.
Hello new people, if you’re just finding
me for the first time I’m doing weekly Marvel
and SHIELD videos all season, be sure to subscribe
to get everything.
I’m also working on a new giveaway that
I’ll explain at the end.
So starting off, if you missed last season,
careful for spoilers from the finale.
I’m going to have to explain season 2 by
talking about season 1.
So I’ll wait just a sec...okay, here we
go.
There is a time gap between the end of season
1 and the beginning of season 2.
Skye is now in full on agent mode.
Coulson has been director of SHIELD for about
6 months and HYDRA Ward is still in a holding
cell.
He’s still part of the show, he’ll just
be the Loki of the season.
The bad boy they stick in a holding cell when
they don’t need him for a special mission.
Oh yes, they’re definitely going to let
him out for some super special missions this
year.
They did it with Loki in Dark World, they’ll
do it with Ward.
I love that he grew a beard, just to let you
know he’s extra bad.
Like motorcycle riding, chain smoking bad.
Just kidding, I’m so much more happy with
what they did with his character in the last
few episodes of season 1.
If you watched any of my season 1 videos,
you know I was not a fan of quarterback Ward.
HYDRA Ward is way more fun.
This is why you stick with the show, they
had the plan all along.
There are a couple of big arcs they tee up
in episode 1.
All the Kree Code.
I’m calling it Kree right now, but there’s
also a slim chance it could be inhumans related.
But feel free to suggest alternatives if you
think you have it figured out.
That will be Skye’s standing order in between
regular missions.
Decode the symbols.
The other big running plot will be cleaning
up the remainders of HYDRA.
To that end, they have several new big comic
book characters, in addition Lucy Lawless
and a couple of Dollhouse Whedonverse people
are joining the cast as new characters that
aren’t from the comics.
Lucy Lawless is playing another Veteran Agent
who will be someone Coulson goes to for help.
Being Lucy Lawless, you can expect her to
be a total badass.
I think the only show I ever saw her on where
she wasn’t a little bit scary was Parks
and Rec.
The biggest new comic book character is going
to be Mockingbird, played by Adrienne Palicki.
She had a big part in the Secret Avengers
storyline with Hawkeye.
That all went down after the big Civil War
event.
She was injected with some super soldier serum
that slowed down her aging process and made
her really strong, but I don’t know if the
show is going to do that.
It’s like a lesser version of Captain America’s
enhancements.
She’s also a super smart biochemist, so
think of her as being like May and Simmons
combined.
Season 2 is going to feature a lot of new
badass women which I’m sure they’ll use
for some awkward comedy with the bigger dudes
like Tripplet and Ward.
Daniel Whitehall, who you might recognize
from Dollhouse or other Joss Whedon whatnot
is playing Kraken.
He’s going to be one of the big villains.
In the comics, he’s a legendary HYDRA agent
who has this special helmet that works a little
like Iron Man Armor.
When he puts it on, he’s encased in hyper
advanced armor and the helmet itself works
a little like the helmet of fate.
In that it imbues some of it’s own personality
on to who ever wears it.
This doesn’t necessarily mean he’s going
to be the big bad.
Because remember at the end of season 1 we
got the tease about Skye’s Father.
They cast Kyle Maclachlan as that character,
he’s playing Skye’s father.
We don’t know anything else about the character
other than he’s a little bit sinister.
If you ever watched him on How I Met Your
Mother.
Think of him as being like the Scary Face
Captain.
I’m also hoping they work in some really
trippy Twin Peaks references.
Also rounding out the rogues gallery is Lance
Hunter who’s playing Nick Blood.
He’s going to be a non-friendly that Coulson
goes to for help.
He’s not a comic book character but he does
lead STRIKE.
Which is like a British SHIELD type organization.
The acronym stands for Special Tactical Reserve
for International Key Emergencies.
Pretty much everybody that’s still alive
is coming back though, Triplett will still
be part of the team and Patton Oswalt will
show up on occasion.
I’m still thinking he’s a Life Model Decoy.
Or he just has a twin he never mentioned.
There will be more comic book characters coming,
but they haven’t announced any besides the
cameos from the Agent Carter TV Show.
Which I will now explain
Hayley Atwell will also be featured as Agent
Carter in a flashback during episode 1 with
the Howling Commandos.
I’m going to do more videos for that show
when it premieres later in the year.
When SHIELD goes on break, Agent Carter will
air in the same timeslot.
That will be sometime in January.
That show just cast James D’Arcy from Broadchurch
as Edwin Jarvis.
In the canon, he’ll be Howard Stark’s
real life butler that Tony Stark later immortalizes
by turning into his AI.
And eventually into The Vision during Avengers
2.
So if it’s a little confusing, the voice
of JARVIS is paul bettany, this new person
is playing the life that character is based
on.
Oh, and if I haven’t mentioned it before
Dominic Cooper will be appearing as Howard
Stark on that show.
I don’t think we’ll see him in any Agents
of SHIELD flashbacks.
I know it’s all starting to bleed together
in our heads.
Agents Of SHIELD premieres next Tuesday at
9PM on ABC.
That’s one hour later than last year.
I do know that FOX will air the episodes in
Asian Countries.
In the UK it’s on Channel 4.
For other countries just check your local
listings.
I don’t know when international episodes
are airing but you might have to wait a week
or find another way to watch it.
Here’s what’s going to happen with my
videos for it.
SHIELD and Flash air on the same night.
Flash is first so those videos will always
go up first.
What I’ll probably be doing is posting my
SHIELD videos the next morning.
Next week will be a little different.
I’ll probably be posting my flash video
extra early, so my SHIELD Episode 1 video
will post Tuesday Night.
Be sure to subscribe to get it.
I will be live tweeting while it’s on TV.
All my social links are in the description.
I’m pretty good about not being spoilery,
but it’s a fun way to talk to people during
the broadcast.
I’m not going to be using a special hashtag
or anything.
But once I settle on a name for our group
here I might do something like that.
The giveaway for all the comic book shows
will be a little different.
I’ll just be randomly selecting people from
the comments that I think are really awesome.
Not the comments, the people making the comments.
So if you want me to see you, you have to
leave comments.
Right now click here for my NON Spoilery Review
of the first episode of Gotham, also starting
next week.
And click here to learn about the new live
action Teen Titans TV Show that’s coming.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!